FIRST, OBAMA'S FAILED RECESS.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
THE OBAMAS LEFT THE WHITE HOUSE
ALMOST TWO YEARS AGO.
CAN YOU BELIEVE IT?
BUT THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO
FORGET HOW AWESOME THEY WERE.
EXCUSE ME.
R.
WITH MICHELLE'S ROCK STAR BOOK
TOUR, THE GLOBAL SPEECHES AND
THEIR DEEP TIES TO HOLLYWOOD,
THEY ARE HARD TO AVOID.
LAST NIGHT BARACK OBAMA VISITED
A INSTITUTE IN HOUSTON, TEXAS,
AND HE CAME OFF AS A MAN WHO IS
OBSESSED WITH HIMSELF.
AND OBSESSED WITH TAKING CREDIT
FOR ANOTHER GUYS -- TRUMP --
SUCCESS.
>> AMERICAN ENERGY PRODUCTION.
YOU WOULDN'T ALWAYS KNOW IT BUT
IT WENT UP EVERY YEAR I WAS
PRESIDENT.
AND THAT WHOLE, SUDDENLY AMERICA
IS THE BIGGEST OIL PRODUCER.
THAT WAS ME, PEOPLE.
SOMETIMES YOU GO TO WALL STREET
AND FOLKS WOULD BE GRUMBLING
ABOUT ANTIBUSINESS.
I SAID HAVE YOU CHECKED WHERE
YOUR STOCKS FOR WHEN I CAME IN
OFFICE AND WHAT THEY ARE NOW.
WHAT ARE YOU COMPLAINING ABOUT?
JUST SAY THANK YOU.
>> Laura: NO THANK YOU.
OBAMA'S EFFORTS AT LEGACY
BUILDING NOTWITHSTANDING, THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO
PRESIDENTS ECONOMIC RECORDS IS
STARK.
AND A POSTER, FAST FOOD
EXECUTIVE AND ONE-TIME TRUMP
LABOR SECRETARY NOMINEE WROTE A
FANTASTIC PIECE IN YESTERDAY'S
"WALL STREET JOURNAL."
HE COMPARED THE END OF THE OBAMA
ECONOMY WITH THE BEGINNING OF
THE DRUM ECONOMY.
CHECK THIS OUT.
GDP GROWTH STAGGERED ALONG AT
1.5% AND MR. OBAMA'S FINAL SIX
QUARTERS IN OFFICE.
GROWTH DOUBLED TO 3% DURING
MR. TRUMP'S FIRST SIX FULL
QUARTERS.
THE INCREASE IN JOB OPENINGS
OVER MR. TRUMP'S FIRST 20 MONTHS
HAS AVERAGED AN IMPRESSIVE
75,000 A MONTH.
BUT OVER MR. OBAMA'S LAST 20
MONTHS IN OFFICE, THE NUMBER OF
JOB OPENINGS INCREASED AN
AVERAGE OF 900 A MONTH.
DURING MR. OBAMA'S LAST 21
MONTHS, THE NUMBER OF EMPLOYED
AMERICANS INCREASED AN AVERAGE
OF 157,000 A MONTH.
UNDER MR. TRUMP, THE INCREASE
HAS ACCELERATED TO 214,000 A
MONTH.
A WHOPPING 36% IMPROVEMENT.
UNBELIEVABLE.
HALF OF THAT, WE ALL KNOW OTHER
FACTS.
RECORD LOW AFRICAN-AMERICAN,
LATINO UNEMPLOYMENT.
CREDIBLE RISING SMALL BUSINESS
APPLICATIONS, AND TOTALLY JACKED
UP CONSUMER CONFIDENCE.
YOU GET THE POINT.
OBAMA'S PATHETIC ATTEMPT TO TAKE
CREDIT FOR THE FRUITS OF HIS
SUCCESSORS POLICIES WHILE OBAMA
CRITICIZES MOST OF THOSE VERY
SAME POLICIES, PATENTLY
RIDICULOUS.
THAT'S NOT THE ONLY THING THAT
DOESN'T WASH IN OBAMA LAND.
>> MICHELLE AND I AND OUR
GROWTH, WE CAME OUT INTACT.
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS THE CORE
VALUES THAT WE BROUGHT INTO THE
OFFICE, PRETTY HOMESPUN VALUES,
TELL THE TRUTH AND TRY TO SEE
THE OTHER PERSON'S POINT OF VIEW
AND TREAT PEOPLE KINDLY AND WITH
RESPECT.
>> Laura: WITH RESPECT?
EXCUSE ME AS I LAUGH.
LIKE ALL THE RESPECT HIS
ADMINISTRATION AND HE HIMSELF
SHOWED FOR ANY OBAMA CREDIT?
>> LET ME JUST MAKE THIS POINT,
JOHN, BECAUSE WE ARE NOT
CAMPAIGNING ANYMORE.
THE ELECTION IS OVER.
THEY HAD SUSPICIONS ABOUT
WHETHER GOVERNMENT SHOULD MAKE
SURE THAT KIDS IN POVERTY ARE
GETTING ENOUGH TO EAT.
THINK OF HOW MUCH BETTER OFF OUR
COUNTRY WOULD BE IF REPUBLICAN
POLITICIANS HADN'T SPENT YEARS
PRECISELY TRYING TO SCARE
VOTERS.
>> Laura: THAT'S ALL
REPUBLICANS DID.
THAT WAS THE NICE STUFF HE SAID.
AS FAR AS THE HOMESPUN VALUES
AND HE BRAGGED ABOUT LAST NIGHT,
VALUES LIKE TELLING THE TRUTH.
>> IF YOU LIKE YOUR DOCTOR, YOU
WILL BE ABLE TO KEEP YOUR
DOCTOR, PERIOD.
IF YOU LIKE YOUR HEALTH CARE
PLAN, YOU WILL BE ABLE TO KEEP
YOUR HEALTH CARE PLAN.
PERIOD.
>> Laura: AND GOOD INVESTMENTS
INVESTMENTS.
OBAMA IS SPENDING HIS
NONRETIREMENT PINING AWAY FOR
THE BYGONE ERA WHEN LIBERALS
DOMINATED ALL MEDIA PLATFORMS.
>> WHETHER IT WAS CRONKITE OR
BRINKLEY, THERE WAS A COMMON SET
OF FACTS, A BASELINE AROUND
WHICH BOTH PARTIES HAD TO ADAPT
AND RESPOND TO.
AND BY THE TIME I TAKE OFFICE,
WHAT YOU INCREASINGLY HAVE IS A
MEDIA ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH IF
YOU ARE A FOX NEWS VIEWER, YOU
HAVE AN ENTIRELY DIFFERENT
REALITY THAN IF YOU ARE A
"NEW YORK TIMES" READER.
>> Laura: YEAH, IT IS ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT.
WE SEE THE WORLD AS IT IS, WHILE
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND CERTAIN
OTHER NETWORKS SELL THEIR OWN
VERSION OF REALITY.
OFTENTIMES THAT VERSION OF
REALITY IS ONE WHERE ALL THE
FLYOVER PEOPLE IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE COUNTRY, THEY KIND OF JUST
FADE AWAY TO BE REPLACED BY HIP,
COOL PROGRESSIVES AND MAYBE SOME
SOCIALIST URBANITES.
THE PRESIDENT DESPISES TALK
RADIO.
WE SPEAK WITH THE SO-CALLED
DEPLORABLES EVERY DAY.
WE SAW TRUMP'S VICTORY COMING.
THE SO-CALLED ERUDITE LIVE AND
DIE BY EVERY HEADLINE, THEY WERE
CONFIDENT TILL THE END THAT
HILLARY CLINTON WAS GOING TO WI
WIN.
THE REAL REASON OBAMA DETESTS
FOX, TALK RADIO, ANY
CONSERVATIVE WEBSITES, IT'S
BECAUSE HE PREFERS LIFE KIND OF
THE WAY IT WAS OR IS TODAY ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
WHERE DIVERSITY OF THOUGHT IS
LARGELY NONEXISTENT AND WHERE
VIOLATORS OF VAGUE COMMUNITY
STANDARDS ARE PUNISHED OR
SHUNNED.
MEANWHILE, WHERE SYCOPHANTS AND
TOADIES, CERTAIN IDEAS WERE
PEOPLE RECEIVE PRIVILEGES AND
NONSTOP ACCOLADES FROM
PROFESSORS FOR THEIR COURAGE AND
INSIGHT.
GUESS WHAT.
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS ARE
ACTUALLY GLAD THEY DIDN'T GO TO
UNIVERSITY OR THEY ARE GLAD THEY
LIVE NOW IN SOMETHING CALLED THE
REAL WORLD.
THEY ACTUALLY GRADUATED AND THEY
PREFER NEWS SOURCES AND
COMMENTARY WHERE THEIR OWN
VALUES ARE NOT UNDER CONSTANT
ASSAULT AND RIDICULE.
BY THE SO-CALLED ELITES.
BUT BARACK OBAMA KIND OF HAS
CONTEMPT FOR A LOT OF THOSE
VALUES, AT LEAST IN A LOT OF THE
VALUES YOU AND I HOLD DEAR.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THAT MUCH
RESPECT FOR ANY AMERICAN WHO
DOESN'T THINK LIKE HE DOES.
THIS LINE LAST NIGHT MADE IT
CLEAR HE HASN'T LEARNED MUCH OF
ANYTHING SINCE HIS SNIDE, BITTER
COMMENTS.
>> ACT QUICKLY ENOUGH, THE FACT
THAT THERE WERE PEOPLE BEING
LEFT BEHIND.
AND THAT FRUSTRATIONS WERE GOING
TO FLAREUP.
IN THOSE ENVIRONMENTS, YOU THEN
START GETTING A DIFFERENT KIND
OF POLITICS.
YOU START GETTING THE POLITICS
BASED ON A NATIONALISM THAT'S
NOT PRIDE IN COUNTRY BUT HATRED
FOR SOMEBODY ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE BORDER.
>> Laura: OKAY, LET ME GET
THIS STRAIGHT.
ANYONE WHO SUPPORTED
DONALD TRUMP, ESPECIALLY HIS
IMMIGRATION POLICY, BORDER
ENFORCEMENT AND THE LIKE, IS
BASICALLY A RACIST XENOPHOBIC
BIGOT OR MAYBE YOU ARE JUST ONE
OF THE MILL STUPID HICKS.
HE HAS AN INTERESTING WAY, HE
DOESN'T COME OUT AND SAY IT BUT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE EINSTEIN TO
READ BETWEEN THE LINES.
IT'S A NEGATIVE AND CYNICAL VIEW
OF ABOUT HALF OF THE AMERICAN
POPULATION CURRENTLY.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
THE DARK, CYNICAL VIEW OF
AMERICA, DO YOU KNOW WHAT IT
REMINDS ME OF?
>> THE GOVERNMENT, DRUGS, BIGGER
PRISONS, THREE STRIKE LAWS.
NO, NO, NOT GOD BLESS AMERICA.
GOD DAMN AMERICA.
IT'S IN THE BIBLE.
THEY ARE KILLING INNOCENT PEOPL
PEOPLE.
>> I DON'T THINK MY CHURCH IS
PARTICULARLY CONTROVERSIAL.
IT'S A MEMBER OF THE UNITED
CHURCH OF CHRIST.
>> Laura: NO.
I GUESS YOU CAN TAKE THE MAN OUT
OF REVEREND WRIGHT'S CHURCH BUT
YOU CAN'T TAKE JEREMIAH WRIGHT'S
MIND-SET SOMETIMES OUT OF THE
MAN.
ALL THE POLISH AND SMOOTH TALK
AND SIDE JOKES OBAMA STILL CAN'T
SEE THAT THERE ARE SUBSTANTIVE
REASONS WHY NOT EVERYONE LOVES